je t'ai envoyé au mariage royal avec des
instructions on ne peut plus simple
ne pas provoquer d'incidents
international
comment ça va tu as fait un certain
nombre de choses stupides dans ta vie
mais ça c'est la cerise sur le gâteau
[Musique]
c'est Henri qui m'a bousculé et j'arrête
très envie de faire comme le prince
ce que j'attends de toi c'est que tu
répares les pots cassée à l'ancienne
la Maison Blanche et le palais vont
publier une déclaration commune
si tu veux j'ai plus de followers que
toi je tiens à ce que tu saches tu
portes tes talonnettes je sais tout mon
chou mais devant les caméras tu as
intérêt à faire comme si le soleil
sortait de son cul et inondé de vitamine
D qu'est-ce que tu comptes faire pour
que le monde sache que nous sommes amis
j'adore traîner avec ses gars
rien ne nous oblige plus à nous revoir
[Musique]
j'ai fait quelque chose qu'il fallait
pas est-ce que tu t'es déjà demandé qui
tu serais si tu étais quelqu'un
d'anonyme je comprends rien à ce que tu
racontes vraiment pas fini
[Musique]
cher Alex tu me manques
bonjour on est dans un hôtel rempli de
journalistes et si quelqu'un vous voit
quitter cet hôtel je brexit de votre
tête de votre corps votre altesse royale
il faut que tu sois sûr que tes
sentiments pour lui sont profondément
sincères est-ce que tu l'aimes qu'est-ce
que ça changerait si c'était le cas
le prince Harry appartient à la
Grande-Bretagne
on peut trouver une façon de s'aimer
notre façon à nous c'est comme si
j'avais une corde accrochée autour du
torse qui me tirait vers toi
avec un peu de chance nous passerons la
soirée sans scandale
la soirée ne fait que commencer
[Musique]